kobe bryant which continues to live on
through his books
what does that feel like to be number
one with the book in a project that you
love so much
it's a crazy feeling to be number one in
new york times it's a great feeling
that was kobe's last e.t interview
before his and daughter gigi's tragic
passing earlier this year
today is the release of the second
installment of his number one new york
times
best-selling young adult fantasy novel
epica the river of sand
vanessa bryant interviewed the book's
author ivy clare
and revealed there was one thing she had
to change in honor of kobe's mamba
mentality
there was one line in this book that
said friends come first
practice comes second and i remember
telling you there was no way in hell
kobe would ever agree to because he used
to always tell the kids your friends
will be there
after practice now to harry and megan
who made a very flirty announcement
they are launching a new podcast company
say it because i think it sounds really
nice with your accent
well i told you arch yeah archwell audio
i mean
welcome to archwell audio no he has a
podcast voice
the duke and duchess will produce and
host a variety of uplifting and
inspiring podcasts
set to launch on spotify later this
month and first up
is a holiday special
[Music]
it will be the couple's first christmas
in america a source tells e.t
they are planning a low-key holiday at
home with archie and megan's mom dorian